Benedict Cumberbatch scene one take one
when did I know I wanted to be an actor
Wow when did Shakespeare know that he
wanted to rival when his starbucks make
his first Frappuccino
[Music]
got me dr. strange attractor only wants
to act and the reality is I don't know
how to do anything else you okay over
there
mmm very important stay hydrated by the
instructions
great acting because training you have
to train hard to act great are we gonna
do anything besides watch episodes of
Sherlock
well now you may be missing a favorite
bus I'll have to rewind it to the
beginning you need to learn from the
master
it won't be easy try the line where's my
mother where is my mother - mother where
is my mother - feel it good if you want
to succeed you have to really want it
and for that to work your art must be
your passion the doctor said it's for
sure the tests came in positive boring I
mean how are you gonna make that go
viral hmm do funny dance
viral mm-hmm I just told him I have
three months to live
Jesus you got the Internet pregnant
again
with Entertainment News this course will
cover everything you're a snake you're a
giraffe reaching up through the canopy
of the jungle voice physicality you're a
bird the wings make you hover over close
your eyes you're on a peyote trip
everything's beautiful hands hats all
the important
[Music]
very good
that's the indie I'm a big bad guy who
has children are my be o meter do you
see from the top down it's an external
to internal transformation acting is for
me about facing your fears and
confronting harsh truths I don't like
your face that's really rude that's
really rad your voice makes me want to
vomit you're an asshole
truth maybe too much truth never ever
too much it's about pushing yourself no
okay I like this that that will get you
a Golden Globe nominee
the only reason to become an act is
become famous and rich and if you
succeed you will touch people
metaphorically you don't have to and
they might want you to touch it can get
complicated just it's a metaphor my name
is Benedict Cumberbatch welcome to an
actor act
[Music]
good on so many levels
you